come on idealities tell them all to
stop one the entire horde to stop
Joran make them stop Khaleesi you heard me what
do you want done with them bring her to me and
those women there you cannot claim them all
princess I can and I will my brother used to
say the only thing the Dothraki you have to do is
steal things better than a boat on the only thing
I've quite good at killing the better men it's
not the kind of Queen and I'm going to be some
say the unsullied are the greatest soldiers
in the world the greatest slave-soldiers in
the world distinction is a good deal to some
people you take a babe from its mother's arms
kill it as she watches and pay for her pain with
a silver coin la sang-gu de if a tricycle a boss
says he'd like you to know that the silver
is paid to the baby's owner not the mother
if you want to sit in the throne your ancestors
built you must win it that will mean blood on
your hands before the thing is done the blood
of my enemies not the blood of innocents how
many slaves are there in yunkai 200,000 then
we have 200,000 reasons to take the city you
will release every slave in yunkai every man
woman and child should be given as much food
clothing and property as they can carry as
payment for their years of servitude [Music]
I'll tell our men to ride ahead and bury them
you don't need to see this you will do no such
thing I will see each and every one of their
faces remove her collar before you bury her
you're the mother of dragons I need to be more
than that I will not let those I have freed slide
back into chains I will not sail for Westeros you
are helping me show them to freedom I wouldn't be
here to help you if Ned Stark had done to me what
you want to do to the Masters of yunkai my god
[Music] you're the mother of dragons I
don't want another child's bones dropped
at my feet if the Mad King gave his enemies the
justice he thought they deserved and each time
it made him feel powerful and right until
the very end I will not have the son of the
harpy executed without a fair trial gather
all the great masters and wise masters and
worthy masters you can find and slaughter them
all I am a queen not a butcher I'm all reeving
groving raiding or raping that's our way of
life no more if her saris had three dragons
and an army at his back he'd have invaded
King's Landing already conquered Westeros
would be easy for you but you're not here to
be queen of the ashes no I am NOT here to be
queen of the ashes well you haven't stormed
King's Landing the only reason I can see is
you don't want to kill thousands of innocent
people it's the fastest way to win the war but
you won't do it which means at the very least
you're better than Cersei we both want to help
people we can only help them from a position
of strength sometimes strength is terrible